[Musique]
nouvelle édition du café politique cette
semaine c'est sonia à boro qui est
invité bonjour bonjour et bienvenue ici
à montigny le bretonneux c'est le
bicycle r ce qui nous reçoit pour cette
émission vous êtes ce 1er adjointe de s
inscrire à l'école conseillère
départementale est adhérente à l'usm va
peut-être commencer par ça justement
aujourd'hui comment se porte le pays lui
dei comme les grands partis nationaux se
remet d'une deux élections qui était
compliqué mais nous nous reconstruisons
et je pense qu'on est dans le bon sens
avec un lien ou non avec les
républicains je vous pose la question
parce que jean christophe lagarde qui le
président de l'udps et au niveau
national a tout de même dit de laurent
wauquiez qu'il était dans une course
assumé avec l'extrême droite
vous êtes d'accord avec ça alors vous
avez bien bien repris c'est jean
christophe lagarde et marle de laurent
wauquiez et juste avant vous parlez de
partis qui sont lus dei et les élèves et
je pense que nos partis ne se vit pas
des sommes d'accord donc pour fait la
distinction entre les deux mais en moins
les parties sont incarnés par des hommes
vous savez dans eu des iris indépendant
et vous assumer cette indépendance août
à discuter la garder et voir comment les
choses avancent lui dit c'est un parti
centriste
ça veut dire quoi être centriste
justement lui dit est un parti centriste
plutôt social plutôt libérale et surtout
pro-européen et c'est en ça que
que j'ai choisie afin de partir au
centre droit lui dei et parce que ça
correspondait à mes valeurs
vous avez adhéré quant à lui dit
justement en 2007 en 2007 et qu'est ce
qui a motivé cette adhésion cet
engagement au sein d'un parti politique
quel a été le déclic
alors le déclic il a été très simple en
2007 monsieur deux bras maire de saint
cyr l'école m'a proposé de faire partie
de son esprit peu pour 2008
quand j'ai dit oui il me semblait
évident qu'il fallait aussi s'engager au
niveau politique et sur un parti et j'ai
choisi lui dis parce que ça
correspondait enfin j'ai choisi à
l'époque le nouveau centre parce que
tout simplement le nouveau centre
rassembler les valeurs que qui me
représenter que je défende il ya eu un
engagement politique très jeune pour
vous comment ça s'est passé plus jeunes
en aide sans de la politique vous
regardiez la politique de loin pas du
tout alors les grands événements
nationaux et est toujours important à la
maison bien entendu à l'élection
présidentielle les élections locales
parce que ça touche et la vie du
quotidien
mais en dehors de ça non je n'avais pas
forcément panda 2
d'atom
partie précisément sur les nations la
politique n'était pas une militante
engagée à assumer plus jeunes pas du
tout mais alors comment ça a été perçu
au sein de votre famille quand vous avez
décidé notre vie personnelle de vous
engager en politique ça doit être une
surprise peut-être alors en fait je
j'étais déjà présidente d'une de ma
copropriété donc les gens autour de moi
qui me connaissaient notamment dans la
famille savait très bien que j'étais
tournée vers les autres vers la société
d'une manière générale donc ya pas eu
trop de surprises les gens bien vécu
même si ça vous prend beaucoup de temps
parce que vous prenez de plus en plus de
responsabilités vous êtes maintenant
aussi conseillère départementale alors
que là aussi ça a été un cap
supplémentaire
oui tout à fait après oui en effet c'est
un juste équilibre entre la vie
familiale et
vie politique donc ils le prennent très
bien ils me soutiennent et ils savent
veut dire à des moments de lâcher un peu
voilà et la vie professionnelle au
milieu de tout ça alors la vie
professionnelle j'ai été obligé de
arrêté ma vie professionnelle lorsque
j'ai été élue conseillère départementale
pour une raison très simple qui touche
tout le monde c'est à dire que la
journée à 24 heures est il donc on peut
pas en pousser les limites travailler
plus les engagements et plus la famille
ça reste évidemment un peu compliqué
quand vous regardez un petit peu
aujourd'hui la politique au niveau
puisque vous y est beaucoup plus
intéressés aujourd'hui que plus jeune
quand vous regardez la politique au
niveau national
vous dites que les choses changent pas
mal et que c'est plutôt bien finalement
moi j'ai pas le sentiment que ça change
beaucoup je parlais dans le renouveau
politique impôts être oui au niveau des
visages on a de nouveaux visages que ce
soit bien oui pourquoi pas mais après je
l'attendais vous dites que ça n'avance
pas sur les idées je ne vois rien où
vous rentrez car quel bilan alors vous
faites on est un nom de la présidence
des manuels mâcon justement m'écoutais
je crois que le bilan moi j'ai pas mal
fait
lorsqu'on a eu le premier budget premier
budget généralement c'est celui
c'est plus dur ça c'est bien on fait
passer toutes les grosses réformes et
j'en ai pas vu beaucoup donc je suis un
peu inquiète pour le reste comment
aujourd'hui alors vous engager sur le
terrain pour refaire passer les idées de
votre formation politique reconstruire
aussi et faire revenir peut-être les
adhérents les militants et les électeurs
verbal udi le centre à moi je suis une
élue locale et donc au niveau 9
c'est quand même très différent du
national je suis sur une ville qui a une
caractéristique très très compliqué
puisqu'on est une ville de 18 mille neuf
cents habitants avec encore 37 % de
logements sociaux et de nouveaux
quartiers de nouveaux bâtiments et à
côté de ça d une architecture des années
soixante dix avec des bâtiments une
école qui va avec
voilà et toutes les problématiques que
ça que ça comporte donc très honnêtement
mon engagement il est locale et
aujourd'hui ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
c'est d'arriver à faire évoluer ma ville
dans tous les quartiers de la même façon
et c'est difficile oui c'est très
compliqué saint cyr l'école était une
bénéficié des politiques de la ville
jusqu'en 2012 2013
quand ça s'est arrêté on a vu le
changement vous savez tout le monde
parle de la prévention spécialisée en
disant cela mais ça sert à rien ça sert
à rien tant qu'elle est est le jouet
part on le sait très bien où d'un an et
demi on voit bien les dégâts et on voit
bien ce qu'elle faisait
c'est le cas de saint cyr l'école donc
aujourd'hui à tout à reconstruire
j'ai toujours eu sur le plan politique
beaucoup d'agitation aussi dans cette
commune de saint cyr l'école et des
changements de maires et des conseils
municipaux qui se sont divisés au sein
des majorités alors je vais pas
reprendre tout l'historique ce serait un
petit peu long de rentrer dans le détail
mais comment vous expliquez tout ça
alors ce qu'il faut quand même voir
c'est l'histoire sur du plus long terme
quand on va quand vous me dites que ça a
toujours été un peu compliqué vous
parlez des trois derniers mandats donc
les trois derniers mandats il
ensuite à 80 ans de communisme est donc
en effet j'avais un bastion communiste
pas tout à fait donc en 2001 la ville
passe à droite
l'équipe est une équipe de conquête et
arrive aux responsabilités le deuxième
mandat stabilise un petit peu et au
troisième mandat bon ben voilà on est à
deux ans de la fin du mandat je crois
qu'il ya pas eu beaucoup de turn over
dans notre équipe
les choses sont beaucoup plus apaisées
je pense que oui il a fallu trois
mandats pour arriver à un peu plus de
sérénité en ce qui vous concerne vous
avez débuté on l'a dit en 2008
conseillère municipale vous êtes devenue
adjointe en 2014
c'est une évolution qui qui se fait au
service 2013 c'est une évolution qui se
fait au sein du conseil c'est la place
de maire vous y pensez bien sûr je serai
candidate en 2020 vous avez parlé avec
bernard de bain alors j'ai glissé
évidemment j'ai entendu parler à
monsieur de 20 donc monsieur de ba a
annoncé
en 2014 lors de la précédente campagne
qu'il ne se représenterait pas en
devenir et c'est pour ça que je serai
candidate je ne me serais pas présenté
contre bernard de oui ou non il n'y a
pas de d'animosité particulière contre
bernard de bain et balla et comment va
se passer alors vous êtes déjà en
campagne comment va se passer cette
période d'ici à 2011 y pensez déjà vous
avez déjà des projets aussi pour cette
commune j'imagine là bien sûr que j'ai
des projets pour la commune
non je ne suis pas encore en campagne
parce que je rappelle que je fais partie
d'une équipe et qu'on a un bilan à
défendre qu'on a des projets à mener qui
vous jusqu'en 2020 donc je suis pas
encore en campagne et pour ma part je
considère que sur ses deux derniers
mandats saint cyr a su se doter des
équipements nécessaires pour l'évolution
de la ville en 1975 saint cyr avait 17
min 18 mille habitants en 2001 il en
avait 14 millions et c'est l'évolution
normale d'une ville sire que la
population a beaucoup baissé et puis là
elle est en train de remonter
on va arriver à un maximum de 20 milles
22 mille habitants maximum et donc il
fallait vraiment équipe et la ville des
équipements publics nécessaires à
l'accueil de ce nouveau public
c'est ce qui a été fait sur les deux
derniers mandats je pense que le mandat
suivant il faut qu'ils soient consacrées
au cadre de vie la fin à la façon dont
on va accueillir ces personnes aux
entrées de ville route la circulation
il peut bien vivre dans la dans la villa
saint cyr l'école vous y êtes arrivé
quand elle est implantée quand sur cette
commune parce que on va peut-être
entendu vous avez une petite action vous
étiez à tarbes
c'était l'avant voile alors moi je suis
originaire de tarbes je suis arrivé en
région parisienne en 95 sur la commune
de plaisir et puis nous avons
déménager sur saint cyr en 2000 ya donc
il ya maintenant 18 ans on a évoqué la
ville de saint cyr le département
peut-être un peu aussi maintenant vous
êtes conseillère départementale cette
expérience nous apporte quoi le
département c'est pour moi je vous le
disais en début de l'entretien le
département vraiment pour moi c'est
l'échelon nécessaire pour la commune
c'est le premier partenaire dès que vous
voulez faire quelque chose dans une
commune vous êtes de suite
tourné vers le département que soit la
compétence est donc le département
d'abord c'est une expérience riche et
ensuite c'est vraiment la
complémentarité par rapport au
territoire
et puis il ya quand même quelque chose
sur le département du 78 qui et qui
quand même assez extraordinaire
c'est cette majorité qui qui est de
droite et de centre-droit et qu'ils
parlent d'une seule voix et ça c'est
quelque chose que l'opposition aimerait
bien de temps en temps alors pas celle
de chez nous puisqu'il y en a pas mais
aimerait bien mettre à mal de temps à
autre ce n'est pas le cas on entend
quand même quelques élus quelquefois qui
qui s'expriment contre les choix qui
sont faits au sein du département je
conseille vandewalle par exemple oui
bien sûr mais enfin il est passé entre
droit je crois donc oui on a tous des
individualités on a tous des choses à
dire et souvent des dépenses est
différente c'est un peu normal mais mais
au-delà de ça chacun est libre de
s'exprimer chacun donne son avis et
c'est la majorité qui l'emportent
il ya plusieurs dossiers qui occupe le
département il y en a un qui fait
toujours un petit peu parlé c'est le
rapprochement avec le département des
hauts-de-seine
vous qui êtes concert départementale des
yvelines vous voyez ça d'un bon oeil
moi je suis pour je suis pour tout
simplement pour une cohésion du
territoire
on a des territoires qui sont différents
très complémentaires et honnêtement je
trouve que c'était c'était un beau
projet parce qu'il verra le jour je ne
sais pas aujourd'hui je pense que le
vrai enjeu ce n'est pas forcément la
fusion c'est surtout la métropole du
grand paris parce que très concrètement
si la métropole du grand paris s'arrête
aux frontières qu'elle a défini
aujourd'hui ça va être très compliqué
pour nous qui sommes les banlieusards
déjà pas mal oublier pour les
départements et pour les communes et on
en revient à la défense de la commune
territoire on est toujours sur les mêmes
sur les mêmes principes
les dossiers qui vous intéressent pas
particulièrement vous êtes présidente de
la commission action sociale solidarité
insertion handicap
c'était un choix ou c'est un dossier que
vous avez donc vous avez hérité
malgré vous alors si jamais une façon
fait jamais les choses malgré soi que
les choses soient claires non je pense
que notre président nous nous connaît
nous
nous assumons sondés et qu'il nous a mis
en place auquel il pensait que ça ne
correspondait le mieux donc dans cette
commission les choses qui sont pour moi
les les plus attrayantes sont d'abord
l'emploi le montage d'activit y est son
bilan je trouve que c'est quand même
quelque chose de l'extraordinaire et je
pense que on doit défendre ce bilan là
et on doit progresser encore continuer à
progresser dans cette optique
et puis le handicap le handicap tout
simplement parce que j'ai une petite
fille de 13 ans qui est handicapé et
donc forcément ça me touche
particulièrement
pour terminer cette émission ce café
politique un questionnaire traditionnel
votre livre de chevet alors en ce moment
c'est le manuel du dard ont écrit par
baptiste stobbe qui est et animateur sur
la commune de saint cyr qui
fontenaisiens et qui aujourd'hui
travaillent au service communication en
tant que graphiste paieront que sa part
2 et bien c'est son expérience de
nouveau papa avec pas mal d'illustration
était assez sympathique le conseil le
dernier film que vous ayez vu un belle
et sébastien 3 avec ma fille c'était
bien c'était et puis pour terminer la
chanson la musique qui vous restent en
tête en ce moment où si on a une ou
alors un morceau de musique préférés
peut-être toujours du hutu plutôt rock
plutôt rock
merci beaucoup sonia bourg d'avoir
participé à ce qu'elle a fait politique
[Musique]